so if this
asymmetry of power is fundamental to jiu
jitsu
how do you discover that how do you how
did you discover the body life
that as a as one of many
methodologies of achieving this
asymmetry um it would be an
overstatement to say we discovered the
body line right body lock passing has
been around
longer than we've been around um but
what i would say is that
in a room full of dangerous leg lockers
you've got to have a way to shut down
the hips and so once we started using
body locks we saw that was one excellent
way to
get around that problem
as with all development it comes from
trial and error
you will often see people teach the
technique to a certain level and
you see the teaching like there's a lot
of inadequacies there
and that doesn't cover a lot of the
problems that we're encountering
and so trial and error is the single
most important part of the development
trial and error in um in the training
room amongst ourselves
in in hard training or no
it never begins with hard training or
everything
techniques are born the same way we're
born
weak and in need of nutrition
uh you have to like this build them up
organically like children
and you start with minimal resistance
and you make progress over time
when you first go to the gym do you put
500 pounds on the bench press and try to
bench press it no you'll be killed
you start off with the bar you build
over time and then one day five years
from now perhaps you really are left in
500 pounds
but only a four would attempt that on
their first attempt
and they're born like children in your
mind first like
uh there's a spark of another one it's
like scientific development
on a subject matter which is
intrinsically simpler
okay there's a sense in which
naive and overly simplistic assessments
of scientific method
may not work well at advanced levels of
science but they work damn well in the
training room with jiu-jitsu with
whether
the the subject matter is inherently
simpler than it is in research science
and as a result
there'll be a spark you'll see something
like there's possibilities there okay
let's
let's puzzle this out let's work with
this and
uh you run into a lot of failures this
you know you've suddenly been oh man if
i
put my hip this way this works really
well then suddenly you try and spawn you
get caught in a simple all my platter
and you're like okay that didn't work as
well as i thought
and then you look to rectify things if
things go on promising research
directions you keep them
if not you discard them well it's funny
you say science
it feels like more like art there's
somebody i really admire
that talks about this kind of ideas
johnny i from apple
he's the lead designer he recently left
but he was
the designer behind most of the products
we know and loved from apple
and when you say designer be more
precise what exactly was he
was he working on in apple the iphone
which which parts of the iphone did he
like the entirety of it
was he a leader of a research team or
was he the person personally responsible
for the development
he's kind of i would say
very similar to your position
he wasn't necessarily the last the
person executing the fine
the manufacturer right yeah of course
but there's the
uh he's somebody that's very hands-on
and it's it's like okay so he worked
obviously extremely close to steve jobs
steve jobs has this idea
we should have a computer that's as thin
as a sheet of paper
and then you start to play with ideas of
like what does that actually look like
the reason i bring it up is because he
talked about
he had these ideas that he would not
tell steve
because he he talked about in the same
exact language as
you're saying is there's like like a
little baby
that it's very fragile
it it needs time to grow absolutely and
then steve jobs would
often roll in was too ruthless you're
too ruthless
this is he would destroy ideas because
uh johnny ive and the team
didn't have actually good responses to
the criticism at first
because when they're babies you can't
defend the baby
uh but you needed time to develop you
need to sleep on it you need to rethink
it the
dream things and all those kinds of
things um it's fascinating you say this
lex because this is
actually the entire history of
scientific development
is literally the story of the
juxtaposition between the need
to protect and nurture new theories
versus the need to rigorously test them
with
with harsh testing that either verifies
them or falsifies them
and learning to find a satisfactory
compromise between those two
is a very very difficult thing when you
look at the
history of science you will see that
there's some pretty damn chaotic moments
anytime there's major theory change
where
all kinds of apparently um
undesirable tricks they use to protect
certain theories
with ad hoc hypotheses etc etc and
uh and ultimately only
time and
success over time will justify a theory
there's usually a period where
when one theory goes in to replace
another there's something of a battle
between competing
uh groups of scientists some of whom
advocate theory a some who advocate
theory b
they often use seemingly
unscrupulous methods to protect or
attack another person's theory they dig
for proofs
and usually some period of time has to
go by
sometimes in some cases it simply
involved older scientists protecting an
initial theory dying off and new
scientists just replacing them with
numbers and
this is a common common theme and the
same applies in jiu-jitsu you know
i've so many times especially when i
first started working with leglocks i
would show
um things i had worked on to
even world champion black belts and they
would try it once or twice
and fail but like it doesn't work and
we're like
you tried it once on it on another guy
who's also a world champion who
has a strong ability to resist it and
that's it no more it doesn't work and
then
uh five years later they would see my
students
finishing world champions with it and in
some cases finishing the very people
who said that the technique would never
work
i mean if there was ever a refutation of
a statement that that's a pretty clear
example
and there has to be a sense in which
you can't be too forgiving you have to
test hypotheses
but on the other hand you can't be too
ruthless either you have to
look for uh promise and and uh
my advice is start slow like again
the analogy of lifting weights you don't
lift the heaviest weights on your first
day you build up
you work progressively over time um
now you also have to have some common
sense here you can't be too forgiving to
a technique if it's repeatedly failing
then and
good people have tried it and multiple
good people have tried and it's just not
working out then
okay it's time to dismiss it but don't
be too quick
you know
you